notre monde est baignée par les ondes
dans la rue dans nos maisons
le bus qui programmera one est de
concentrer saison pour les transformer
en matière le procédé était vraiment au
bois nous sommes au stade du prototype
ne connaissons encore mal les limites
d'une telle technologie il ya comme une
intrusion dans les systèmes non e le
gramme n'auront bientôt interagir
physiquement avec notre mans comme vous
et moi ça se propage comme un virus dans
nos machines
ce ne sont plus aux machines
on a perdu tout contrôle sur les
hologrammes
vous êtes nos pantins nouvelle ère
s'annonce et l'humanité dans fait pas
partie
l'armée est démuni c'est un ennemi d'un
bojan ils s'adaptent ils se transforment
et il se régénère
doit vaincre le mal par le mal seul un
être de la même nature peut le stopper
on m'appelle voltage les hommes ont
conçu pour les protégés de mes
semblables
où hologram seule une erreur de
l'histoire qui m'appartient de réparer
on m'appelle paul tedj je suis départ la
foule à quai par la foudre mais ennemis
périront